y en a qui ont des enfants dans la salle
on n'a pas encore d'enfants et quand
t'as pas encore d'enfant tu te projettes
un petit peu par exemple on a un pote il
n'arrête pas de nous dire eh moi mon
gamin c'est sûr il va jouer au psg c'est
bien le mec il est ambitieux concernant
son futur fils mais dans son projet on
voit qu'un seul hic le patrimoine
génétique parce que quand on est venu au
five honte à regarder jouer tu étais
vraiment galère donc si un jour ton fils
joue au psg
sûrement que c'est pas toi le cas autour
de nous il ya plus en plus de parents et
le problème c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on
en vend il tente de nous convaincre
ils cherchent à nous recruter tout mais
qu'on a des yeux on te voit en fait tu
as perdu 12 kilos et a des cernes de
bâtard et ou pata du vomi sur les pôles
malgré sa tous quand même nous sortir
vegas une expérience de ou faut vraiment
que vous vous lanciez dernier avec excès
de gueule qui nous a dit c'est une
expérience d'au vraiment que vous
lanciez il était 3 heures du matin on
était à gare du nord
c'était un [ __ ] de drogués on va y a
pas d'âge pour faire un enfant le bon
âge pour faire un enfant c'est quand tu
te sens prêt il ya plusieurs signes qui
montrent que c'est pas bon moment de
faire un enfant tu as par exemple si tu
mets tout ta tuque dans les jeux vidéo
enfin pas tout de suite si tu mets ton
réveil à midi on fait pas tout ceci tu
mets des claquettes chose n en fait pas
tout court bah tu tapes merci à tous
[Applaudissements]